in the past few months more than a half
a dozen Americans have been killed or
attacked while in the Dominican Republic
we've teamed up with Fox & Friends and
sent Grif jak and Jenkins down there to
investigate what is happening exactly
they're supposed to keep people on the
island and joins us exclusively live
from the Dominican Republic tonight Grif
hey Tucker good evening when it comes to
finding answers we find that the
officials here are mostly stonewalling
us hotels aren't going on camera to talk
to us in the tourism ministers out of
the country so we took the hunt for
these answers straight to the top Danilo
Medina is the president of the Dominican
Republic he's been in office since 2012
he was at a groundbreaking event
yesterday so we win with our questions
here's what happened watch mr. president
mr. president I want to ask you about
the the recent deaths of four Americans
here at resorts yes mr. president
just a comment sir now one of the
gentlemen you see there Tucker that the
president Medina's talking to you is
Frank Ranieri he's one of the wealthiest
investors in tourism in the Dominican
Republic he was willing to speak to me
afterwards he says he's worried about
the impact that these deaths may have on
tourism here are some of what he had to
say listen when people come to
all-inclusive I'm not an all-inclusive
Hotel people have a tendency to drink
and eat more than often and that's where
the problem begins because when you get
everything free then you make a party
about out of it so sometimes some people
may not be capable of of drinking and
eating as much and that's why you have
incidents with heart attacks and things
like that but isn't it's not a problem
of the minibar president medina is a
very responsible man and I'm sure he
take his involved personally supervising
and making sure that all this comes to
an end and he gets a clear picture of
why that happened now when it comes to
the minibar you heard mr. Rainier you
mention it there the Hard Rock Casino &
Hotel in Punta Cana that we showed you
that video last night of the minibar
where you have the full fifths of liquor
in there they're issuing a statement
tonight sending their sincerest
condolences to the families of mr.
Robert bill Wallace as well as David
Harrison and said that the ongoing
investigation will continue saying this
quote we can assure you the safety and
health of our guests is now and has
always been our highest priority we
currently implement beverage protocols
including purchasing sealed and unopened
products from licenced and reputable
vendors as well as daily inspections of
all products served throughout the hotel
bars in in-room liquor dispensers so at
least the hard rock they're responding
to our investigation but you know it is
going to be the final
toxicology pathology reports of the last
four individuals that have died here the
Americans that have died here I can also
add to this the hotel resort behind me
Tucker here the Bahia Principe this is
where that Maryland couple Edward Holmes
and Cynthia day were unresponsive didn't
check out on time they were found dead
in their room on May 30th their attorney
telling me about 30 minutes ago they
just got the bodies back today to
Maryland he will do his own independent
autopsy in toxicology reports we'll find
out what those results tell us when
they're available Tucker
so those the people mr. neary suggested
to you may have eaten themselves to
death because the food was free well you
know he's clearly a a billionaire on the
island that has a big stake in all of
this and he pointed out Tucker that
didn't seem a possible explanation no
physician but yeah it it tells us one
thing Tucker and that is that they're
scrambling in the wake of these tragic
deaths and certainly hope no more happen
yeah
that's pretty amazing proof Jenkins
thanks a lot we'll see you tomorrow